he came to visit us or came to visit our
brothers in Cardiff I mean Cardiff here
today in Charlotte with
somebody likewise
today's episode will be full of it full
of benefits
so I'm gonna give the Karima to Hassan
Somali to introduce our uncle and our
Sheikh talah
I think that
it's a beneficial opportunity to sit
with
and just discuss his life story because
especially as he relates to the youth
where
knife crime in the UK or gun violence in
America is on the rise in many cities
and many families have been affected by
this
and the Sheikh when we hear his story
alhamdulillah it can serve as a warning
and likewise an advice to the youth to
avoid this lifestyle because not only
does it harm the individual not only
does it harm Society but it also harms
people that you are meant to love like
your parents your grandparents your
brothers your sisters
and the story of the shared is an
example of how as well Islam
alhamdulillah changes a person's life
where a person the Sheikh he spent over
43 years in prison where he was
incarcerated at the age of 15 and he
recently came home alhamdulillah and he
is a pillar of the community assisting
brothers and sisters an aiding Society
in general so this is one example of
many that we hear about on a daily basis
and sometimes people may be unaware of
these stories because they're not inside
of these communities where Islam
alhamdulillah has changed the life of
the individual and when the individual
for example he comes to join The Wider
Society alhamdulillah they not only ate
themselves and their families but also
the wider community and we see them
involved in great service again which is
one of the blessings of the religion of
Islam so inshallah
you know tell his story and I'm sure
brother may have some questions or
comments Allah
to bless the sitting and making a
benefit for us and likewise all of our
brothers and sisters
yeah yeah
my brothers in Islam has informed you
that I was in a situation in which I did
over 43 years and the penitencies in the
United States of America
and through those trials and
tribulations I was fortunate about a
blessings of Allah to come into the full
of Islam
was had an overwhelming impact on my
life and as well as the Gods in which I
followed through those years of
incarceration sure how old were you when
you became a Muslim I was 17 when I
became a Muslim
and I was blessed to come straight into
Quran asunder
ment from Allah
and I didn't realize the benefit of it
until the years later was this
1974.
which is a long time during that time
and when did you come home I came home
2017.
2017 and
Allah was good to me because he's
answered my supplication and brought me
home and brought me in the
company of the people in which I strive
all my life to be a part of which is the
people of Quran and the Sunnah with the
understanding of this will happen
when you went to prison in 1974 correct
no were there a lot of Muslims in there
or uh I was it people of the Quran the
sooner at that time it wasn't a lot of
quranisms at that time there was a group
called The Nation Islam and they had
many numbers they outnumbered us and
then you had the cardians a group of
cardi Annies
and uh very little Shia he had a group
called the most Americans they were
pretty strong in numbers which is a
nationalist group like today's land what
is the belief uh they had a
shirky belief in which in the force
belief in which they believed that a guy
named Noble Drew Ali was a messenger in
the prophet
Dave was aligned or their belief was in
accordance with the Nation of Islam so
they claimed to be Muslims but yet they
believed there was another prophets
after Prophet Muhammad no no and of
course I guess the teacher of Islam
clearly that takes the person out of
food of Islam no because the last
prophet Muhammad
what about the Nation of Islam if you
could just explain the nation of Slam is
a group that started in around 1931
and the leader of it eventually became a
guy named Elijah Muhammad Elijah pool
and they were very instrumental and very
strong in decisions as well as out in
the streets of Philadelphia prison yeah
they're very strong in the prison
and they had a belief in which they said
that God came and the person of a guy
named Master Ford Muhammad which is
disbelief was the disbelief and they had
a false prophet was a guy named Eliza
Muhammad he claimed to be a messenger in
the prophet which is also a false
statement to cook and it turned uh it
was a problem between them and the Sunni
Muslims as everyone would know is that
Joe yeah it's a prison in jail very very
contentious very problems matter because
of their belief system and they were
strong at one point right they were
strong very strong at one time when I
was over when I went over at holmesburg
it was probably about close to 150 of
them and probably a good 25 Sunni
Muslims That's How Strong they were you
know and uh so when he went inside the
first time I mean how did you become
Muslim who gave you that one well about
four of us another young brother came
now from a prison called White Hill or
Camp Hill
I had knew him previously before he went
there and he came back he came back and
he was talking about the Quran and
Sunnah now previously before that I
didn't have no religion I never believed
that no other religion but alhamdulillah
and I was basically on Fifth so I want
to check so your background your family
were Christians or yeah yeah you know
but shaky Christians
Africa or Caribbean uh no not this is
America
right for down south but they didn't
they didn't stress religion you know you
know they didn't really stress it and
you know they didn't have no impact on
me and my brothers
so so Chef before you got locked up you
got influenced by The Gangs well I was a
cold-blooded gang member you know
following the example of my brother who
was older
it was what would say a traditional
thing in which you follow those that
were before you your example was those
that were older than you and at that
time they had a pecking order and gangs
a lot of my mother's brothers and stuff
like that that were way older than me
were gang members and at that time the
way games was especially in Philadelphia
and probably United States but generally
in Philadelphia
most of the ones that preceded us were
gang members family was gang members
you know some of our mothers and acts as
gang members so you had a pecking order
from which you would say the little Pee
Wees to the young guys to the to the
older guys and the other guy they had a
ranking order called the peewee's the
young boys the Juniors and the seniors
and they were different age ranges and
as you would get older you would
graduate to another level if you're a
Peewee from about 10 11 years old you
would graduate eventually two years when
you come 13 to 14 till young young boy
when you became 15 to 16 you graduated
to another state became a junior
17 18 you became a senior 1920 he was an
old head and everything that preceded
before that was the old heads right so
it was a packing order which you grew up
in it so you were indoctrinated into the
gang collection
that Islam alhamdulillah helped change
your mentality and your outlook oh how
do you live that no doubt about it
because as one other brother said I
never got a chance to become so steeped
into it once I became a Muslim right he
said he meant a lot of those best he
made a statement that I never became
thoroughly corrupted with the game
mentality It Slam seed me you know
so so when the Bravada gave is that
no just accepted it because you know
naturally I knew it I always knew in my
heart because at that time you had about
and I was a young guy we were young guys
there's four of us and you had about two
or three adults it was Sunni Muslim this
is called an awful lot Muslims meaning
those the right ones and you know you
know we knew the nation's land wasn't
and I just always said them the real
Muslims I just instinctly knew it right
and then when uh Hassan that was his
name he came back from Camp Hill and he
was talking about Islam and you know he
had a set of cell about five four of us
and I knew in my heart I said this this
is this is the this is the truth but you
know that's what the Third Kind of
one the great Egyptians mentioned one of
the Islam the Miracle of Islam he goes
in line with the fitter no you know in
line with the federal corrupted even if
you've been like crazy life stopping and
shooting but you know meaning that you
believe there's only one God you know
you believe there's a creator for this
creation that's why you know Islam is so
powerful because it just hits your
father straight away
[Music]
then I rode home to some of my gang
members family so look I'm about to
become a Sunni Muslim so some of the
gang members are saying well you could
still become the SUNY muscle part of
gang I said not me I said I'm about to
I've had to cut that cut off from
outside
yeah they were telling him that he could
become a Muslim but he still could be a
gang member oh so you can't believe it I
mean you should stay with us now yeah
yeah and then we had some there that was
with me in the prison because I had some
code offenders and I said nah I said I'm
going all the way if I go I have to go
all the way hello
into Islam in totality no and
alhamdulillah with the statement has the
right to be Western in truth except
Allah our Allegiance revolves around
them not around any gang culture no no
one of the other things about the gang
culture where that was unique
it was about loyalty too yeah
see so Allah being all our al-alaim
he had
cultivated me right to come to this land
because loyalty was above anything to me
I was loyal to No Doubt to the gang to
the point where that meant more to me
than my own life but when you became
Muslim and yeah
correctly yes
that meant more than to me then that's
something sadly among some of the
Muslims who still are involved in the
gang culture they lack that loyalty to
Allah is Messenger salallahu that
they've been commended with because that
has presidents over everything yes Allah
says in the Quran
don't give presidents to anything before
Allah
because our human nature to be loyal you
know and if someone helps you in the
heart in a hardship in a hard time
you'll be loyal to him I understand but
the the best loyalty it has to be
revolved around Allah is Messenger based
upon Allah
so the this culture 6 which is a phrase
where the characteristics priority
honesty truthfulness you know but you
have to implement them in the correct
manner as the other pagans they have
this some of these attributes
characteristics but Islam comes in and
fix it or tell you how to implement
itself perfect it yeah perfectity
so when they their your lips are they
say to you like uh you see you can still
be a Muslim oh yeah yeah you know
because I was such an ethical part in
that stuff that you know all my life you
know at that time I probably was up 17.
see so you know from the age probably
from nine and a half to ten oh you're
there that's all you knew I was loyal to
that thing for years you know because
the examples that's before most gang
members is
the ones that's above you so I want to
share so you started with a gun for
since you were 10. yeah really nine and
a half years old
yeah yeah
it's a family basically yes they
cultivated you yeah and you mentioned
many of your
yeah that's the family members that ran
some of the gangs that was you know that
ran at an aunt she you know the 50 she
was part of you know that's how how long
that thing was how intense it was it was
it was a cultural thing
you know it's like a religion man you
know
in prison there was a time alhamdulillah
obviously you've told us about it but
you know it's different to today because
we have literature alhamdulillah you
have the noble Quran which is an
interpretation a translation of the
meaning of the Quran you have many books
with Muslim the six books of Hadith and
books
[Music]
other than that right but he was telling
us when you were locked up at the
beginning when you were incarcerated
that there was like one translation
available oh you have one Quran over the
house of correction oh and the elders
the older guys had these guys was guys
was over 18. most some guys probably was
like in their middle 20s it was two or
three of them they had it on another
block right and they would not let us
touch it you know one and we were trying
to get it you said you used to write it
down they used to write it down to give
us little pages of Swords right and we
were like well this is the shame man
like this so let's let's have let us
have it it's not yeah
you know we had the most like
four of us including myself they would
just sitting down write down passages we
see them at the gate they'll give it to
us and you know that was the Holy Grail
you know we're like you appreciated it a
lot boy that was it you know we today
copies are readily available oh yeah
they have translations of the meaning of
the Quran and they would they would uh
what they call Fanatics they were
Fanatics give us phonetics the fatty had
you know and so awesome you know handed
to us right and we were going over here
you're transliterate we call it
phonetics right you know see so uh you
know if the information wasn't strong
right it wasn't strong but one thing we
did get from them the fire pulling this
lamb right and the pillars will be mad
you got that from him she said that's
the foundational thing when I moved
upstate because I got sentenced when a
greater for December 74.
with the State Penitentiary but not one
dead I was there for about a week and uh
the city muscles a little stronger than
him no that was six or eight and it was
dead but by that time they uh I think it
was about a good 70 of them right Master
subsidies and you probably had about a
good 450 nation of Slam guys right yeah
the cardian is there and that was that
was basically dead right and uh
literature start coming a little bit
more
then I went from there to eventually
Huntington State Penitentiary when I got
the Huntington you know it was probably
about a good 35 Sunni Muslims about a
good 90 or 100 FY guys now most
Americans have become a stronger but you
got about a good 30 most Americans
because they they're in that Pittsburgh
area and Huntington is in central
Pennsylvania so I'm really running in
them more in numbers we had them down
the county
right but now in the penitentiary in
Huntington you start to see him more
numbers right they got their own
structure they got their own religious
services so we run it to them now right
so so now the letters is starting coming
more now you get books on from the older
brothers they're giving us books on the
sahabas
we're getting books on the sea of the
prophets of the summer the Hadith come
in and play I remember we first got our
hands on cyborg Heart by Sheikh Muslim
Khan right 1976 right yeah the first
translation hardback right this joint
Kazi Publications that's the green the
green one we get that one right whoa see
so now that's like you know how did you
feel oh that was it right see so
it's a funny thing right but uh
mashallah you know in prison you at that
time you got to remember that prison was
real prison because at that time you
still had people there from the 40s in
the 50s because it was and then you know
when I first got locked up they didn't
have contact visits
you know you didn't have the contacts
but you had he was behind the screen or
the glass okay you know they only had
six phone calls a year you know there
was no such thing as a traveling or the
uh the buses and all that stuff it's
before that you know when I was a
Huntington they had a train come through
there once a day right one time a day
and then most of our family members
didn't have cars the ability to travel
nothing see so the visitation thing
wasn't there when did you become the
Imam in um greater food what year 1986.
yeah he was the email
even when I recently I visited one of
the prisons to give some lectures many
of mashallah the brothers they know
because he was in Imam for like over 20
years yeah about close to 30 years
so you you start
you became immersed alive starts
teaching the people or yes that's a
unique experience right you talking
about the map because before you
get there you had to begin where you
started at yeah see and uh wow that's a
story within itself the history is soon
to Islam in the prisons because
no doubt what happens out in society
affects the prisons
well outside Society yeah yeah see
because when you go back and assaudi
Islam you had to understand especially
in America a lot of those older guys was
ex-militants
Black Panther Party radicals and things
of that Nation they came into Islam 1771
right and uh the influence from the
street played a part because they would
come in and teach classes and at one
time they were given the discernments of
things of that nature but eventually the
brothers and Jill freed themselves from
them
but they didn't concentrate on prisons
much other than just getting they called
the mobility classes it's 75 of the
seven nobody put interest in prison
right because at that time they really
didn't look at prisoners as true Muslims
or something no at one point shift like
for example so the Sunni Muslims were
sort of United right obviously yeah they
opposed the Nation of Islam because of
the heretical beliefs yeah so you had
for example the sun is generally at one
point in time they were together yeah
but various groups from the outside yeah
started to cause splits well
amongst those who ascribed the Sunni
Islam what were some of the group ships
that caused the split originally well
originally at first we had this group
called The Dark slamming movement they
based the hair and influence over all
three muscles what they tried to do was
they try to unite all Sunni Muslims
Ghana yeah yeah New York right and in
Philadelphia
was the Iman
right they had the big they had the
Pledge of Allegiance or no yeah we
didn't we didn't find about the bear
into the split Habit in 1976 right
because they tried to bring it into
prison see and look these groups causing
splits amongst the brothers who were
once all together
and some people they accused you know I
had a son and they said if he's of
causing splits but in reality these
groups had their own agendas
the brothers started you know gaining a
great understanding of you know the
methodology of the Senators
because at first all Sunni muscles were
literalists they took the parent little
meaning of the grand all that was in the
place
the position the position of the harbors
all that was clear but as I said they
didn't emphasize trying to bring this
stuff into prison right as it must be
because nobody concentrated no prison
you know it was like you know they they
ain't nothing but and I hate to say and
then but your house Muslims you know
they ain't really important you mostly
you know and they you know they've been
coming there probably get a couple cool
fees you know things of that day I was
in prison yeah but yeah you know as the
Muslim Community and then he became a
proper Muslim when he came outside the
community began to grow yeah in the
middle 70s yeah that's just like it uh
so they began to come into the prisons
once the numbers begin to grow
so now they're looking for Manpower to
building communities the outside outside
brothers from the streets So eventually
they come into the prison
in 1976 I was up Huntington this
happened now greater for Massachusetts
we heard about it the bear
I said yes uh from the streets first of
all they infrastrated the community
right because they used to come in and
they had a portion of Brothers at this
time the sunnis became strong there's
about a hundred and ten of them right
they were strong Spirit they were strong
but he resigns and they shipped him so
another but the Ishmael the Kareem takes
over
so he lets them back in they start
coming in they secretly give about 25 30
Brothers about
so she give back to this person to the
dark Islamic movement okay right
what would they believe we sort of kind
of found our lady with they was twisted
but she don't know they didn't what type
of beliefs did they have though they
generally had a nationalist belief when
they did we come to find out later that
y'all do Kareem out of New York with
Sophie she kind of find out later on but
they never brought Sufism in right see
so so what happened was a sheikhood uh
comes back from Court he was down court
for about a year and a half he comes
back Ishmael Iman but the Sheikh sahib
resign they transferred him to Western
Penitentiary so he tells Ishmael he
talks to shake Hood he brings the
sheikhood's attention that he has a big
apple the door move
you got a bet
he said well you're taking orders to
somebody from the street do the
community no
he said no
he said I think you should tell the
community that you have a bad with
somebody because the bear belongs to the
Khalifa yeah so now all this coming into
play now so Ishmael don't say nothing so
about two months later Ishmael gets up
and resigns
he says I'ma resign but I'm a nominated
Shake Hood as a man right so they they
brought it to the abdomen the admin
deferment they brought it to the
community the community affirmed it so
sheikhood becomes a man
so about exactly two months later it's
my illness gets up after gentleman said
we had to pull up from your community
because orders come from the street that
y'all didn't take the bay out so we
can't then I had the first split in the
penitentiary sunnis so that they become
so volatile because you had to remember
you got like close to 450 Nation to slam
guys
and the tension between us is there so
probably amongst one another yeah so the
brother said what if you do don't spit
the community
so become so intense where it's almost
infighting the most assuming is about
the split and that's one of the
consequences because Innovation causes
Bliss
so what causes splitting
and these students would have noticed
now big eyes coming into the ummah they
had to speak out and cry for the truth
but the hustle
so the reality was splitting and what
cause division is the Innovation so when
you see a student of innovation not
because they just wake up in the morning
and feel like it you know because they
want to preserve the deal afterwards the
The Innovation caused splitting amongst
the Muslims and looks of animals and
that's why the prophet saw Allah
regularly in his sermon he used to one
against bidad
and there was nobody there yeah because
alhamdulillah was among the Companions
and I've seen the danger better they
started with the bear
all right for the bear and that split
the community up so the students got
weak
about 35 40 poured away from the
community about 25 30 what the people
took the bear out and said who was left
with about 25 30 people
so you know that the soonest Community
is disarray but you see the evolution of
the days are bad because later on down
the wine down down the line the guys
that took the bear out with the door
they begin to get they give a bear to a
Sufi named Jelani sent me a 79 so now
what you guys the influx of methad books
and then you know like they said
Innovation may start small but it is
very very important because the seller
will protect us and our families from
deviation is guidance that's why you see
some individuals warning and guys those
books because those books made the books
itself expose their methodology
and it can increase increase it gets
worse and worse and lead to disbelief or
to shook and even one of the proofs of
that as well because the seller they
derive these rulings or these statements
from the Quran and the son of the
prophet salallahu and biographies of the
companions when the individuals were
present at the time of some of the
Companions and they were saying
subhanallah
and they were throwing the pebbles no
they said those individuals later on
they were with the khawaris
so look they started with the Buddha in
terms of the way that they made Dicker
and then they ended up joining the
qawwal
sometimes
and I have to I have to uh you know
thank Allah
[Music]
but he did Muslim first I mean bukhari
first 1976 in his introduction in the
beginning of it he lays down the three
categories of tawheed he lays down sugar
act boy escort he lays down kuffa right
Shook You Know music
he lays down uh a major hypocrisy mind
which is which was something very
instrumental and that helped the dollar
grow that was the key that was the
key
with the understanding of the sahaba
educating the people about till he now
educating the people about Sunnah and
the dangerous
that was a blueprint we used me and a
few brothers that was our blueprint so
now you tell my 1976.
it's on my 1976 right
so now like I said eventually the guys
that gave the bear out to the door they
eventually got flipped it became Sophia
so they begin to flood the prisons with
methad
and Methodist
information so us being solid and
after he and soon to begin the battle
that says whoa what the Lord area where
you get this stuff from
so here's the Battle of Akita taking
place Chef you said they used to
photocopy some of the books and send it
to another we used to photocopy we photo
first we typed it out we type it out and
that became too too overburdened he said
damn which book shift if you give us
this week you know we started we uh we
have no doubt those little uh uh that
was one of the major books we had you
know and uh so you just type it out at
the beginning
yeah
the prisons
then we found we got to hook up in the
school building where we was able to go
on the ground and get photocopy
highlights as well shift the importance
of effort regardless of where you are
yeah you know that that would require
effort and sacrifice we just start
writing even not only in Pennsylvania I
was writing everywhere guys in Jersey
everything we just start writing in
there yeah then eventually how many our
people begin to translate some books we
was always saying we need our people
that start translating books we need our
people stop translating books the larger
yes
you got them in the night they started
getting in there you know we said we
needed our people to start getting stuff
but you got to give Sheikh Muhammad Khan
you know him Allah man his props because
that was crucial in my influence nah
right that was crucial because that was
like the late 70s that was 76. no middle
70s right and it prepared us when the
Sophia started doing that stuff because
you had information we had information
yeah and one of the good things was I
caught the vase was on color
that was it you know because I could not
get past somebody saying something
in the same breath with the law Isaac
jealous says something the Quran or the
prophet said something I could I I just
we couldn't see it I mean I you know it
just couldn't register right question
Chef um later on who were the scholars
of the Sunnah that were most influential
in the prison system
they were there they were it I mean I
got the sisters from uh brother
brothers wife sent me the sisters in
1991. those those was the thing so even
though
he was all the way in Jordan oh yeah he
had an influence over Brothers no doubt
about it that's one of the things
was very clear yeah see one of the
things about Sunni Muslims when you
filed in the statement of the Prophet
saws he said when he says
the prophets one of the things about the
pure Sunni Muslims and whatever Allah
says and what the prophet saws said we
take it right and nothing goes above it
and nothing could even stand towards it
or against it so whatever Allah said in
the book or whatever the person Hadith
because that was it you know because the
goal was and I still I got the first
time I read all nine bukhari's was in
1979 they were all paperback
I finally got my hands what happened to
Jewel at the crayon you know in the
Olympian brother brought in when I was
at Western Penitentiary in Pittsburgh he
brought in my capacity he said I'm again
he brought him in but that was it I just
you know you buried yourself in the
Hadith right yeah sorry so what is the
first book of vanity you read
the first book about Abandoned was uh
let me try to go back in memory Alabama
yes we got our hands on that you know we
had some stuff up in bass
right you know we have some 10 things
notified slam right
we had on rules they were coming right
but one of the great neighbors of Allah
was to get their literature in the print
attemptions because we were like and the
the two feet boys the Divas got all this
stuff flowing in there for turkey and
South Africa man that we rumbling these
guys we could Rumble them because we
understood this position of the aimah we
understood the position of the four
imams you know we were Rumble them but
we didn't have the literature see so in
prison especially that time when you
didn't have the TVs and stuff is
probably this is reading was a crucial
see so they was flirting they stuff no
internet it was all reading no you know
you know we could we could Rumble them
guys you know verbally but we didn't
have the literature once we got our
hands on we just intensely flooded the
whole system with it you know I mean I
met guys from the federal systems that
had our stamping their Master's such
copies of it come home so how you get
that it's one of the brothers brought
that the FED joint he said wow long egg
bar right see so this is a lot of Thomas
Dower and it can't be stopped all right
it just had to be represented with the
right people
because you've been prisoner for 45
years 43 43 years yeah so you've seen
and you're observed the development of
the dawa and the increase of the
diversity of ER in prison people except
in taiwa no you don't see it when you're
doing things for the sake of Allah
without at first it ain't until I came
home I really see the impact right
because when you in the middle of the
struggle of the battles all you're just
doing is doing things for the sake of
all type of reasons world above
everything else you just battling it
when you come home when I came home and
I began I come to Germantown I'm seeing
brothers and stuff instead and I'm
meeting them standing now I'm seeing
brothers that was in jail with 35 years
ago they did
and I don't forget all about them
you know and he's like hey remember
yeah you just you know you you know you
I forgot all about until I come down to
Germany now I seen them I said you know
and then I ran across a lot of good
Brothers in Charlotte but they were what
are they supposed to be
how do you
you know see the growth when you came
home oh wow it was dead you seen the
groove for the dog but then you've seen
the group for the toilet I'm taking it
to another level see because we could
only take it to a certain level with our
limitations and decision I want you from
uh
Muslims
[Music]
you know only thing I've seen they have
down my way of Morris American temples
the remote Hunter area that has given
you you coming out to a community
mashallah you know with the the brothers
you know so now you're busy as well you
are doing that inside no and you're
outside now doing that too that teaches
the class with the new Muslims as well
he helps out with in the Dao Center like
three times a week so what is your
advice you to Young Brothers there for
Muslims and non-muslims because
alhamdulillah you lived you had your
jail your time you know before you
became Muslim you know pre-islamic days
and he accepts Islam because we know
that as said No One have understand the
true meaning of Islam and the blessings
of Islam except those who have tasted
both sides so is advice to the people
out there about a lot of people one
thing you know about the youth is the
ability to look towards certain examples
and certain influences and cultures
and what you want to do is find a
positive example right and in particular
with the Muslims which I could truly
address is that
you have to learn the biographies of the
companions of the Prophet saws because
there's no better example no better God
for us in filing their way you know just
to cut you here so alhamdulillah we are
not in need as one of the people uh one
of the best Malachi said he said we do
not have a room within our time our
schools are not Warriors or The Warriors
are not schools
bless him he was not looking outside for
Role Models when he left sahaba the
biographies of the Companions and the
biography before that of prophet
Muhammad you took them as your role
model so the sahaba's lifestyle is still
applicable to our time no no so this
doubt of we don't have no one so we're
looking out for
anyone that is not true no and even the
scholarship yeah the scholars were Role
Models even though right I was trying to
get there that's the point the uh you
know you begin with rasulullah says for
example because he he is the maraba
here's the cultivator as a kid or the
nurture the woman right and he nurtured
and cultivated this sahaba of the
Prophet sallam but in this example he
guided us to what the role of the
element
because who can be hired in the
inheritors of the prophets you know see
so by us attaching ourselves to the
sooner the prophets of Summer in his
Global companions it is only incumbent
on us to test ourselves with all the
matter the early man they positioned uh
being the forbearers and the carriers of
this down the Defenders and protectors
this downward it's so crucial for us to
test ourselves to them because without
them we would go astray
with them we will be on the Hop for the
prophet saws told us that Uma will not
agree on error in the hand of the Lord
is over the jamai who is he talking
about he's talking about earlier he's
not talking about Layman that's right
he's not talking about any uh time dick
or Harry yeah he's talking about earlier
as the Sheikh adorable which explains in
this fight okay when Allah's messed
itself some talk about the holyhead as a
prophet he says
you know
that any price yeah even the you know
someone said
Warriors and the Warriors are not
intellectuals that's according to
him many of the scholars will let him
have sacrificed their time and their
effort for the defense of Islam yeah
yeah when he got killed by the uh
the boys in Afghanistan
we would definitely connected
to the brothers in the street strong
because we were there then we were the
leaders so we were definitely connected
them and it was connected to brothers
getting information from the UK you know
everything was coming together see
everything come together eventually the
hawk always come together because the
Hawkers won there's only one path to the
hockey it's not several paths see you
may be here you may be there but if
you're striving for the hawk and you're
all striving towards pleasing the law
span of what I'm the final example to
publish our son you all eventually gonna
come together because there's only one
truth right you know take you back to
because you said you grew up in a family
on a household when everyone was the
members of a gun so even for the
non-muslims they should make sure that
our good models or role models for their
for their for their children because
children up to the to the parents and to
the all the brothers where's the youth
the youth is always looking towards
those the young people look they're here
and they see as they grow up they don't
know me they're not to the point where
they're able to educate themselves and
learn from their education because they
lack wisdom understand the things of
this nature so the first thing that they
look is they look and they listen
see so if you look at the prophet sallam
you'll see that he always concentrated
on many cases the youth they've been
abios and it's things yeah go lamb and
he's teaching them things he's
nourishing because of it that's crucial
right they have to see the value of the
examples of the early the valued
examples of the people of knowledge
because the success of the Uma comes
with filing them that is the limit of
Allah
since the prophet Sodom has died and
went forth in the sahabas he's left us
with a clear path a clear way of God but
as we mentioned earlier the statement of
the Prophet saws really my um I would
agreeing out of error and he had of
Allah at the end of the law is over to
Jamiah you know they had to go the ulama
allows the um to be as I would say
bassoon
free from uh
a bit going straight I would like to put
it that way
without Scholars like sheep without
Shepherd you know see so and you see it
all in the history of this land a lot of
jail have always raised I would have met
a guy that um when they had problems
when they had
probably difficulties in Akita and Men
I'm in handball you're going to tell me
you see it all the way to you it's been
badass Alabama
what did he say to them he said I don't
see any of the companions
amongst you meaning who's understanding
the Quran for you who's interpreting
interpreting the Quran for you yes you
know we can sit here for a long time we
can get more benefits from your
biography or your life God bless you but
you know this is
bless you with the biggest and the
greatest blessing yes
mentioned to you about you being in
prison for 43 years you said do you
remember what you told me yes I kept me
away from a lot of bad senseful things
like that you think I'm in prison but
Allah putting you in that place
there's wisdom behind it Allah saving
you from outside from many many
disasters and many calamities I don't
know if he told you but he was sentenced
to life he was never meant to come home
oh subhanallah life forever they changed
the law
a lot I think like uh with yeah if maybe
what five ten years ago 2012 they they
they they ruled oh right but when he was
in prison tell them he said I was
always certain I knew I was coming home
he said I was making do I tell Elijah he
said I didn't have doubt I got Brothers
out here now that's juvenile life is the
40-something years with us and before we
went up there was there was doubt they
Muslims they was down I told them I said
we're going home
right because I know I needed that to
cool my heart out
right you know and did you oh I went
there twice and unless and and one and
the brothers can witness this and many
of them out here I wanted to get at the
feet of the islands this is this is the
this is a message to everyone in prison
if you put trust me
and get close to Allah
[Music]
um
foreign